have you ever had a player who you
trained up and then they got that big
deal and they kind of threw you a little
bonus
like hey yo i appreciate you bro hit
this this for you yeah a few guys
for sure but i never asked either though
but yeah a few guys right can you tell
us who have looked out
nah i wouldn't want to do that but i you
know i've gotten
uh s550 someone's bought me that player
wait someone bought you a benz
yeah i got um you know i have a
rolex uh bunch of jewelry that's like
their favorite thing they want to budget
um yeah you know somebody a [ __ ] car
yeah jesus
but that was like years and years of
grinding and they got you know they got
a life-changing type contract
and then they were like yo thank you
thanks for for whatever you contributed
for sure that's crazy man
is that like do you have to pay the
taxes on the car you know that's so
funny you said that cause at the time
i wasn't really i'd really just started
making money money like the last two
three years so when this happened i
wasn't
i was like damn the insurance the
repairs
all of that yeah so you know i was uh
that kind of like messed me up a little
bit but
you know i didn't yeah i had to pay the
insurance and you know pay the
regular site but you paid the car off
completely so that was cool wow